this capsule we will approach the concept
of language modeling in the
synovial business model that we have
view that models the attached distribution
between the category of a document and the
document we can indeed see this model
there as dividing the calculation of this
probity modeling this
probability there in two parts but
firstly a category model
which is all about a thought that involves
week when the cac priority on the
classes and a model that assigns
probabilities on words by being
given the class and this part there if
what is called the language model
so generally a model of
language we sometimes say model of
English is a distribution on the
text ie on sequences of
words so more precisely what that
means that if I have a document
w 1 up to wd but a language model
will be able to assign a probability
to observe this document there for parity
from w 1 to w so in the model of
business moutinot but actually the model
of the language range is super simple
then that was one of the goals actually
so that leaves so simple
suppose the words are made generate
independently in the document being
given the category this is it
actually assumes that among other things their
demo is not important so obviously
that would not be a very good model of
document
when writing a document is the
next word we write depends
obviously words previous then this
we want to write so clearly
dependencies between limoux and
for some applications other than
classification of documents
a model that assumes that words are
their demos and important point is
clearly in machine translation into
voice recognition need them
of language models that are a lot
more powerful ones that will start to
to treat the relation between the mobilities
a language model that often used
this is called the mg model
this model, which is often used
for in translation systems
automatic or voice recognition
so this is a model that tries
to improve on the language model
used in a model of
classification of documents
assuming that the mmo a sentence is
actually generate or eventually start from
a few words previous in the same
sentence or in the same document
precisely in a model ng we're going
suppose the probability of words w1
until wd in a document it's equal
to the product of the probability of each
words w hui given hates -1
my previous
so the words at the position i - n + 1
up to 10 - 1
for this fact in all they - weapons at
previous is a first property
models called model and g
we call them model ng because so
firstly i'll define you a gg
it's actually a sub sequence of
enemy that we extracted from a corpus we go
see a concrete example of this early time
and we call them ingram model because
that in fact these models will be estimated
from the 2nd g frequencies we're going
see extract or calculated from a
corpus so of a set of documents
we will also notice that in fact a
ng model this is the equivalent to a
model or a n order markov chain
- and so we in the capsules on the
networks stolen kisses but we got
concentrated on model of my order cop 1
so that would correspond to a model a
gramoune would be equal to two so a
model where the next word idea not
only from the word preceding the position y
younger and in general the
model 1 g we can not depend on
only from previous mount but from
two months previous too my previous
and institutes
so let's keep what we'll see
we speak of a ng so magic no
that we are a corpus that counted only one
collector document have lived a bad
or v learning fast so we have
applied pretreatment where we have
applied the vocabulary with the four
words as we saw in the examples
previous
so in this document there in our
corpus there are united g so united grand
pot n equal to 1 of which five different
so 5 a big difference
so actually father 70.1 prove
learning and to wc 17 a g and there
actually has five different from
scion collector a bad and
learnings are the five united g
different we also have 6 bis g big g
for the case n equal to two and they are
all different
the first big g these people will be
comma therefore these two Mauritians to this
that is 9.1 2.1
we have a bad 1 to ivg and this up
the end of the sentence
prove learning prove it does
actually 6.6 g and they are all
different and not one that is equal to
another in my picard list we have
then 5 trigram tri g for an equal to
3 and again are all
different
so with the same reasoning we have
pierced pts 1,1 which the first price sorting g
here during comma a pot so will a
sequence of t3 the second sequence of
3.1 at the v and institutes but still a
times they are all different and we
could continue like this in extract
the 4 g the 5 g and institutes and
besides, out of curiosity we can
extract statistics from different
and g
and observe historical trends
google provides a tool for
do this or the
the corpus corresponds to the lines they
have digitized by doing the
character recognition for
scan all the books of different
moments in history and that's
possible to see how often
we observe different g as and
measure for their different years the
time so it can be denied to them
consult on you encourages to do it
ok rome and to comment what we
does not lead where we learn a model and g
commented on what we finally adapted
to statistics
present in our in a corpus of
Documents
we have several documents to do good
like me we did finally way
similar what we did in our
document classification model
that is, we will use
relative frequencies so the probability
in my ng model that who is going and adapted
to my body more drive so his
probability that w illi mo equals w
given the help - previous ermo
it may be the number of times that the
word w follows the words wy has less between
st up wi - in my body according
twice that I observe the soft w and that
this word is preceded by a lesser word
previous on which I condition
here and for this to be this option
who normalizes who are 1
but I will be divided by the number
many times I observe it's less of a
gram there so the country blue flies -
between st up to wai -1 and the standard times
that I observe them and that this big g the
share in this 1 - 1 g there is followed by a
other word any way a little more
formal it's going to be the sum on all my
gw frequency documents
- next end up double life -
hours followed by w
its frequency of 20 grams of gold each
docks
1 pt / the frequency of my united g is
less a follow-up of any moment
I use the star symbol to say
the number of times that I observe that
I observe it's a less than a gram has it
followed by any other word is
so I'm summing up those frequencies
there for all the documents bp one uses
assure me that my distribution is going well
well this summit so let's do an example
so let's imagine we want to calculate the
distribution of the following word given
the two previous words so in this
In this case, we would have three
we would have a price and suppose that
does I want the volt is conditional on the
word that follows since I before
model of and by putting same name as
in my corpus the pattern frequency
basic is 5 since the frequency of
big markov type sort of 25
language models be 10 and that
finally the number of times that
I observe model of anyone's
what other word it was 200 years had
finally the sum of all the elements
that I have here but because if the way
that I just wrote calculating estimate
and there my model and learn it but
given it's going to be to say that the
Belgian policy follows model of 128 5
so the number of times that bill sui
model to divide by two hundred and 200 the
number of times I see model of
followed by any other word and I
do the same thing to mark things
to be 25 out of 200 then the language its
parity is 1.10 out of 200
what will be important to women by
against this approach the naive sell the
same problem that we saw with the model
for documents to know that it's okay
to be fairly easy on on new
documents to get probabilities to 0
it would be very important to smooth
models in bold and actually a whole
literature on different techniques
of smoothing of models and g
we are only going to see 2 so I
recalls that the reason why
it's important to do that
does more ng and lons - it's going to be
therefore more frequent the probability
ultimately or the chance they
do not appear in our corpus on
the statistical calculation will be high so
the more the arm of leningrad clio
chances we will never have
observed that we have never observed on
a range there is so a way of high school
it's to do the same thing as in the
document model know how to make a
smoothing delta where I'm going to add to
numerator a constant of ltte
positive and to get a model that
sleep again I take the
world and the top I will multiply by
the number of words in my vocabulary
+1 so to restate the body or w
would not be in my vocabulary would
bad so it's the same approach that
previously I have the same two terms
hamon numerator claudine denominator
but I add a positive constant
car than anything that's in my
vocabulary and imported workers have
null and Thursday here aims by that term there
to make sure I do have a
instruction that so summon in my
previous example if I had a
constant rate smoothing is equal to
0.1 and that the size of my vocabulary
it was 999 but in this case what
jaurès and the numerator the frequencies
sorting g 5 plus the constant of
smoothing 0.1 divided by the number of
Once I have the big g tracking model
of any other word plus the
constant smoothing times the term ap
that's it 1 0 point 1 x 999 the
fifth it so healthy and so that's me
would give new probability
better smooth in this case ci which me
among other things, to deal with the case
where I have a word that is great than ever
appeared and that assured me that the words that
a very basic frequency have not a
influence too much on the calculation of
probabilities
because if we observe that models of
language that was good quality of 10 m 2
0 before because we had never seen
language models in my caucus
now a non-zero quality of 0.1
over three years to a last technique
smoothing that I mention is the
smoothing by linear interpolation so
the idea to get an idea to make a
kind of weighted average between
several models and g for values
dell different so when a model
unique g
a model bi g a model tri g is
located up to the n that I have
so choose here so this will be
mathematically it corresponds to what
so
my high school model by a vector of
settings that the social peas
different ngram that I'm going to call from
the amdh to the probability according to this smoothing
by linear interpolation to see w
following a less than one gram lever
way of placing up to w no less than one
it's going maybe the man 2.1 times the
probity associated with an immigrant so united
This is a model that does not depend on
previous words foiles m2 for longer
the soul of twice the social significance big
raemdonck it exceeds summit of the mount
previous plus the soul of three times the
pole t of a sort g that depends on both
my previous and so on until
the value of 1.3 alas what is
important is that it's true in
weighted average so that means that
the
hamdaoui hairs should peak at 1 and
should not be positive so were
the blades of i must also be
fat or equal to zero and typically goes
take baraki strictly legal that m
among others if we only have the sorting range
as in our example the trio models
of language in frequency 0 if I did
linear interpolation smoothing
imagine that the big g mode then the
language gram is present to him in
my body puce
but that means that by smoothing by
Linear interpolation
the probability are also smoothing there that
I observe language given model of
your bigger than zero because and that
noting that double parents than amdh
odors that is the weight associated with the
big g language models so whoever
will associate a priority to the angle
only from the previous word of
foccart long as the water slides
sweet is bigger than 0 it's
sure and certain that the probability here
your greater than zero since the
probity this forces to be greater
that 0 or if he liked alain had been
strictly bigger 0 the still so
we would have a strictly more product
great than zero because the probability
to see languages
this the environment of which Russia would be
also larger of zero since so
I have two languages ​​in my body more
I obviously only have the word there so
we see this is another way of
make sure the frequency gaps 2
we do not necessarily have a probability
equal to zero and among others the g as
frequency 2 0 have brought to associate who
is zero and this will allow us
to have no instability in the
quality of priorities better
generalized to new documents that
are not exactly like what we have
in our corpus